Hello and welcome to Python bites where we deliver Python news and headlines directly to your earbuds. This is episode 269
recorded February 2nd 2022 and I'm Brian Okken
And I'm Luciana
and
I'm Brett Cannon and we have Brett. We so we invited Luciana on and we decided to have Brett on also so
uh, we got have some fun Michael's actually,
gone this week, but hope he enjoys listening. So hi, Michael. And, and we'll talk to him next week.
So before we get into the topics, though, I think people hopefully know who Brett is.
Brett Cannon, you've been on the show before.
A couple times.
Yeah.
And then...
Thank you very much for having me back spontaneously.
Spontaneously. Like minutes ago, we said, Hey, we should get Brett on. So Luciana,
Welcome to the show. Can you tell people a little bit about who you are?
Thank you. Yes, I am. Well, let's see. I work with Brad on a Python extension for Visual Studio Code,
but I'm a program manager. And yeah, I'm very excited to be here in the show. I was
telling Brian that I used to listen to Python Bytes going to work back when we worked on offices.
So it's really, really cool to be here.
- Yeah, nice.
Well, thanks.
I'm glad to have you here.
So let's jump into the topics.
We have an abbreviated list of topics,
but we'll make it fun anyway.
I'm gonna start us off with Rich CLI.
So Will McGugan,
it seems like we talk about him every show,
but this is cool.
So I was like, Oh, I'll try it out first.
And I'm already hooked.
So RichCLI is,
I don't know, it seems lame if I describe it.
So you install it.
I installed it with PipX
because I just want to use it everywhere.
And then what it does is it does like pretty printing
of stuff, like you can give it a file
and basically that's what I use it for.
Maybe it does other stuff, but you can give it a file
like example.py or example.markdown or something.
And it will do the rich printing,
pretty printing right on your screen in the terminal.
That seems like not that big of a deal, right?
But it is so cool 'cause it's all like nice colors
and you can have themes.
And I used, what?
You can do pretty printing of JSON.
So it'll format your JSON for you
without having to reformat it.
You can do a dash M flag for Markdown.
I've been doing that to see my Markdown
and it does some cool stuff with Markdown.
Although supposedly we're like with Python files
and C++ files and stuff,
it's gonna do syntax highlighting based on extension.
I'm wondering why I gotta pass in a dash M for Markdown.
It seems like it's dash MD should work fine, but anyway.
- Could be my immediate question was
why do you have to specify the dash M just for Markdown?
And then like, and then there's some flags that's cool.
Like, like whether, whether or not you want to use it
with pipes so you can,
for if it doesn't, if it's piped to something,
it will, it'll strip out the formatting stuff
like the color codes and whatever,
but you can force that to be on.
Well, I wanted to, I tried to use it with a big file
and it just flew past me.
And, and then, so I tried to pipe it to more or less
and it, it stripped out the formatting.
And so, well, I tried to fix that
and then more or less don't handle that.
And so, and this was just yesterday.
I'm like, kind of really be cool
if RichCLI has supported paging within it.
And so today, Will said,
"Hey, I added paging to RichCLI."
So RichCLI now has paging, so.
- Of course he did.
(laughing)
- Like within a day.
So anyway, pretty cool projects.
Have either of you checked this out yet?
- I did the exact same thing you did.
I used PIPX and sold Rich yesterday, Rich CLI yesterday.
One thing is I will say I use a,
I've actually been using a replacement.
So this is kind of like a replacement
for the cat tool on Unix, right?
And I've been using an alternative called bat, B-A-T,
that's implemented in Rust and has a lot of this as well
in terms of color syntax and stuff.
But I'm willing to bet Rich is,
which I'm willing to bet,
Will's gonna move a bit faster.
So I'm just gonna probably switch over
to using Rich CLI over bat and just see where this goes.
But I mean, come on,
Will even made the output look great.
So.
- Yeah, so what-
- Sorry for the output for the help, it looks phenomenal.
- One of the things that I noticed was that
the default theme,
did the coloring was,
didn't look quite right on the black background
that I was using.
So I just, I exactly, I was using it for cat.
So I just aliased my cat to use rich
with the Monokai format turned on.
So Luciana, would you use this for anything?
- Yeah, I was gonna say I'm behind, I haven't tried it yet.
But once I saw the amazing things they have there,
it's quite a few.
I was like excited to try it out.
So we'll do it today, hopefully.
- Yeah, cool.
Well, let's switch over to debugging.
- Yeah, so I guess most folks, I don't know,
at least I, when I started learning Python,
I used to debug using print statements,
which is like, no shame in that, it works very well.
I still do that when it's like for real quick things,
but I wanted to bring up this awesome tool
that we have, DebugPy.
It's a debugger for Python,
and you can use it like as a CLI tool.
You can also just import it and set breakpoints normally.
I am a big fan of UI debugging,
so I actually prefer to use it built into the Python extension
for VS Code,
which is the thing that we work on every single day.
So, yeah, I wanted to bring up a few features.
They're really, really cool, and I find very helpful,
and it helps me save up a lot of time
when I'm debugging code.
So the first one of them
is kind of like conditional breakpoints.
Yeah, sorry, go ahead.
- No, no, go ahead, neat.
- Yeah, it's super neat.
And this conditional breakpoints is something
that I bring up because I guess when you're trying out
debugging for the first time using the UI,
you set up a breakpoint and then you hit it there
and then you always reload the window
or reload the debugger, sorry, to hit the breakpoint again.
And then you keep stepping over
until it hits a condition that you want.
And in this GIF there, they have an example in TypeScript,
but it works on Python files as well
once you install the Python extension.
But basically, you added the breakpoint
to insert a certain condition so that the debugger will only
stop when that expression is met or the condition is met.
So one example there is hitCount.
So you can imagine if you have a for loop,
and you really want to stop when, for example,
after 10 iterations of that loop.
So you don't want to stop on that breakpoint
and hit the step over 10 times.
You just want it to stop when it hits 10 times.
So you can do that with the hit point.
You can also add expressions.
So if you know, like, oh, I want the debugger
to stop only when this variable gets the value of,
I don't know, 5, then you can also do that.
And it's pretty cool.
Saves up a lot of time.
And you can also do log points instead.
If you're not interested in breaking the execution,
just want to make sure that line was executed.
So it prints out on the output that, hey, this is,
we hit that point.
This is like a log point,
so it doesn't really break anything,
but it's very informative.
- Cool.
So this is an extension for VS Code?
- Yes, I believe most IDEs support that same feature,
but it's a feature that I always recommend folks
to look for in their IDEs or editors,
'cause it does save us a lot of time.
- So to be clear about the tech stack on this,
so there's a couple of layers to this.
So at the bottom layer is PyDevD by Fabio Sdrazny.
We have him on contract as a consultant
to do anything we need to have get fixed and stuff
and just support the project.
Because on top of this, we have another project
that we have called DebugPy,
which implements what's called
the Debug Adapter Protocol or DAP.
It's a meant to be a language agnostic protocol for
debuggers to talk to editors comes out of VS Code.
It's used by Visual Studio as well,
and actually it's now used by Jupyter.
This is how Jupyter was able to launch recently with
debugger support.
'cause actually run debug pie.
And on top of that we have support because we're
VS Code extension.
We support the debug adapter,
so we ship debug pie in box right now for
supporting this.
Although we are talking about breaking the extension,
breaking debugging out to its own extension
so that we can actually update it
at a better cadence with debug pi
'cause we can do platform specific V6s now,
extensions for VS Code.
So we'll shrink that down a bit for our users.
- So is there like a tutorial somewhere
that has like all of the cool Python extensions
that I need for VS Code to get VS Code
with Python to work really great?
Yeah, we have our get started tutorial.
It has like it doesn't have a lot of extensions,
so there's definitely more extensions
that I find to be personally cool.
Maybe we could have a blog post about this
and like cool extensions for Python specifically
in VS Code 'cause there are some of them.
I think Don Giovanni from,
he's the one who created the Python extension
before it was Microsoft thing
and Microsoft hiring him and everything.
So he has a one that I always talk about,
which is the Python environments manager extension.
It just displays the environments
that it can find on your machine
and what packages are installed there.
It's kind of like a environment viewer and it's pretty cool.
It's one that I always tell people about.
So.
- You know, a deep dive into all the useful extensions
to add would be a great testing code episode.
Just saying.
- I love that idea.
- I like it.
Okay.
Well, speaking of plugging stuff,
I want to take a moment to thank our sponsor.
So this episode is sponsored by Datadog.
Datadog is a real-time monitoring platform
that unifies metrics, traces, and logs
into one tightly integrated platform.
Datadog APM empowers developer teams
to identify anomalies, resolve issues,
and improve application performance.
Begin collecting stack traces,
visualizing them as flame graphs,
and organizing them into profile types
such as CPU, IO and more.
Plus Datadog APMs live search.
So you can perform searches across full streams
of ingested traces generated by your application
over the last 15 minutes.
Try Datadog APM free for a 14 day free trial
and Datadog will send you a free T-shirt.
And actually I have one of these purple T-shirts
and I love it.
So visit pythonbytes.fm/datadog
or just click on the link in your podcast player show notes
to get started.
Awesome.
I gotta pay the bills.
So where are we at now?
We're back on me again.
Unless Brett, you got something right out of the blue
you wanna talk about?
Put you on the spot.
- That's okay.
I believe you've talked about exception groups
on the podcast already.
I don't, oh yeah, I think so.
- Yeah, so just 'cause DataDog, the sponsor,
obviously cares about tracebacks and stuff.
One interesting thing that's coming up in terms of a PEP,
it has not been given to the steering council yet,
but there's actually a PEP coming up
that's gonna add a Dunder Notes field,
potentially, to exceptions.
This actually came out of the exception group work
because Zach from Hypothesis was working with it
over on that side and realized that it would be convenient
to be able to kind of just basically literally,
the name says, add a note to extensions
to kind of help explain why this came about.
And so there's a PEP coming that's going to basically
just allow libraries and stuff that work with exceptions
to just attach a little note saying,
this is why this happened, more than just a little thing,
especially for exception groups,
you can kind of get kind of big and murky
by having a single note added to it
to help explain why this came about.
It's hopefully gonna help make it easier for users
to understand a bit more why something happened.
So.
- That's pretty neat.
I like it.
Nice.
I got some feedback recently
that I'm not covering enough test stuff on Python bytes.
So I'm gonna try to,
I'm gonna try to solve that.
I'm not gonna cover test stuff every week,
but I've got a test thing this week
that I'm pretty excited about.
So Simon Willison, great guy,
he wrote an article called "Documenting Unit Tests."
And this, wow, it's old.
It was came out in 2018.
I just noticed it.
So yeah, there's the internet for you.
But it's like, it's a super cool idea.
So the idea is we've got tests like pytest
and other test runners, you can do anything.
he's using pytest to test your source code, but why not?
And Python has all these introspection things you can do.
So he's using introspection to look at the code
and then introspection to look at the documents
with his test code, and then make sure that there's
some items that are definitely in the docs.
As an example, so in this, his example in the blog post
is mentoring data, his project dataset.
And so the test for this is right there.
So you can go take a look at what he's doing,
but he takes a look at the repo.
And for instance, for all, if he adds a config option,
he's got to test to make sure
that the config option gets documented.
That's cool.
So it's just tests or fail.
If he forgets to document a new option,
also plugin hooks and different views within dataset,
they all have to make sure that he has special,
The views, like he wants special pages for each view.
So it makes sure that there's a page there.
So I just, there's a couple neat things here.
Just the concept of using tests to make sure
that there's things documented.
It doesn't tell, he makes a comment that it's not telling,
like a lot of tests, it's not telling you
that the documents are good or documented well,
but that they're documented at all, which is good.
Same with our code.
Tests don't necessarily tell you
that your code is perfect, it's just that they're tested.
The other thing that I wanted to point out about this
is there's some nice use of features of pytest.
So there's a nice use of fixtures and parameterization.
So he's got like the views, for instance,
he goes out and looks at generate,
like goes and gets a list of views from the code
and then use that list to have a generated test
to make sure that each of those views is tested
or is documented.
This is a nice idea.
I've been trying to do that sort of
generated parameter lists.
I'm trying to do that more in my code
because it's just kind of a cool idea
to generate your own test cases.
So anyway, good job, Simon.
- Yeah, as someone who spends more time reading code
and writing code, I definitely appreciate this initiative.
It's very much better to have documented code out there.
- Well, a combination of like making sure
that the test, the documents are tested
or things are covered.
And then also I think a few episodes ago,
we talked about a project,
projects using generating documents themselves.
So like for instance, instead,
if you're gonna plop your help text in your document,
don't copy and paste it, use code to generate that.
And then it's always gonna be correct
if you got it in your build system.
So nice ideas.
- And it was about using cog, right?
- Yeah, that was it.
Cog, I forgot.
- Yeah.
- And what I really love about that is
when I came across cog a long time ago,
I thought I gotta have a use for this,
but I can't think of it.
But this is the perfect use
because we always often do that
within our like little readme or something
is just to plop a little example of code
using your tool, whatever library you have.
So having cog generate that for you is great.
So I think I need to go back and do it.
So I've got a little toy project called cards
that I use for teaching testing.
And I changed the interface for it for layout reasons.
The tables that I was using
didn't show up in eBooks very well.
So I switched the table format,
but then I forgot to change the readme.
But if I had had cog in place,
I would already be doing it.
So it's a neat, my first thought was to write tests
to make sure that the output in my readme
was the same as the code.
But I think a better idea is to just have
the readme generated.
So I mean, either one works, but both are good ideas.
- Yeah, and to tie this back to this point,
Simon's the one that actually started the trend on Twitter
of everyone using cog to use this on their readme.
At least that's how I first came across it.
And then I subsequently saw multiple people do it.
And then I finally had the same reaction you had, Ryan.
I was like, oh yeah, I've been looking for a reason
to use cog for ages.
I never quite had one.
I was like, this is a great one.
So I went and updated the readme for the Python launcher
to use this to generate all the URLs
for downloading the built binaries for it.
So it's great.
- Gulf binaries?
- Built.
- Built binaries, okay.
- 'Cause I tried to build the launcher
for like a bazillion different platforms.
- And I'm grateful for that 'cause I'm using the launcher
like almost every day now.
- Oh, fantastic.
- We are, thank you, Brett.
- Well, so let's pop over to talking about ourselves.
- Oh, that was such a good, wow, I'm impressed.
Yes, pep673 self-type.
I heard from, well, Brett Canundar
that it has been recently accepted.
And it's interesting for me, because I'm now
learning more about types in Python.
I'm very new to it, admittedly.
And I thought it was interesting,
because, well, it adds this away to another methods that
return an instance of their class.
And they give a very cool example there of a class.
There's shape, and then we have circle,
and here it's from shape.
And then shape has this method called setScale,
And then the type that returns is shape,
because it returns self.
And for circle, it returns self as well.
So it's a type circle.
And then it shows there are some, for example, editors
that may throw in error when you call circle setScale, which
is a method from shape, and then setRadius, which
is something from circle.
But once you call them, it will say error,
because shape doesn't have this method that
is specific to circle.
So to have this better way to frame that
would be to return self.
And it was accepted.
And it's very interesting.
I feel like it seems very clean to me and a very good solution.
So I'm personally excited that it was accepted.
It was very well explained as well.
And that was real.
For people on the podcast who can't see
what Brian's scrolling through, basically,
think of capital S self as the return type
for all those class methods you write
that construct an instance of your object.
This is what this is built for, right?
It's fantastic.
If you have the from whatever method,
class method on your class to construct
that instance of that class from something else,
you'd now have a return self with a capital S
versus specifying the exact class it would have returned.
So you don't have to worry about what that's going to look like
and having to worry about the spelling
or any of that forward declaration problems
you can have if you don't do
from Dunder Future import annotations, right?
Where it's like, oh, I'm referring to a name
that doesn't exist yet and Python throws a fit
because that object doesn't exist yet by that name.
So it solves a couple problems like that,
but it's really basically if you write class methods
that construct instances of that class, it's great.
- Well, I don't, but I probably will now when this comes out.
So is this part of 3.11, do we know?
- 3.11, right, yes. - 3.11.
- Nice.
- Yeah, so you can probably get that probably today,
if not in the near future,
from the typing extensions package,
which kind of tries to do a back port and forward port
of anything in the typing world that's experimental
has been landed but not in a release yet.
- Okay.
- And I believe the type checkers,
I don't know if they all support it yet,
but I'm sure very shortly they will all support this.
So you can get to it today.
- And then we get, we keep people that are writing tools
like Flake and Black on their toes,
catching up with all these changes.
- Well, luckily it won't hit them 'cause it's all typing.
So just strings to Black and I don't think Flake
but like mypy, pywrite/pylance, pytype, pyre,
all those type checkers are the ones
that are gonna have to get updated for this.
But they were all in on the discussion
of even proposing this.
- Nice.
But is that, will you repeat that?
So all these people writing these tools
were involved with these sorts of type processes?
- Yeah, so the way typically decisions
around typing happen, especially from a static typing
perspective, I don't want to make statements on Pydantic's
part in the dynamic typing world,
'cause there's kind of two parts to typing, right?
There's the general typing as in,
oh, there's the concept of typing now in Python,
but there's the people who do static typing, right?
And that's the kind of thing where you add your type
annotations, your type hints, and you run a tool later
that somehow reads them offline, as it were,
like mypy or PyWrite or whatever.
And then there's the dynamic typing folks,
that's like Pydantic where during runtime,
they actually look at the annotations.
From the static typing perspective,
there is something called the typing SIG.
It's a mailing list and all the major static type checkers
all work there together to try to figure out
where they wanna take things and kind of what gaps
there are in terms of typing.
Basically, how can they move typing forward in Python?
It's also a place people can go to ask for help
if they have a generic typing question
it isn't too tool specific.
But to answer your direct question, Brian,
the tools that are involved there,
which are basically all the type checkers,
static type checkers that I know of.
So there's PyWrite, which underlines PyLance,
which is what we use for our completions in VS Code.
There's mypy, there is PyType that comes from Google,
and then there's Py that comes from Meta.
- Okay.
- Wow, dizzying.
- Yeah, although, I mean, one of the nice things
about all the peps, right, is this is all backed by specs.
So there's not a lot of crazy deviation, as it were,
from the semantics.
It's more of a bug if someone disagrees.
So they're all pretty consistent,
but some of them do a bit more like inferencing,
like PyType does more like runtime inferencing
and other inferencing to try to kind of fill in the gaps.
That's actually why Google wrote it, I think,
to help them move over to Python 3,
start introducing types to their code base.
- Yeah.
- So they all have slightly different strengths
and weaknesses, but they should at least type wise
more or less, once they've all implemented the same specs,
lead to the same type outcomes as it were.
- Yeah, okay, cool.
- See, I learned so much about typing
just by listening right now.
- Yeah, well, we're to the end of our normal topics.
- Yeah, so it was announced in my team
that Black is no longer in beta version.
So version 2020.1.0 has come out.
So it's their first stable release, I believe.
So that's very exciting.
I really like the highlights that they have there
that Python 2 is no longer supported.
(laughs)
- Yeah, I think that's a good thing.
Python 2 is no longer supported.
(laughing)
- Nice.
- So that's a cool announcement for the week.
And the other one that I have is to remind folks
about PyCascades 2022.
It's happening this weekend.
It's remote.
Tickets are on sale.
So if you're interested in joining the event,
it's really awesome.
It was my first Python conference
and the community there is just really amazing.
So again, remote, join us this weekend.
- Pike Cascades was your first conference?
- It was.
It was back in 2019.
- Was that the Portland one?
- It was in Seattle.
- Seattle, okay.
Yeah, I guess it was the 2021,
it was in Portland right before everything shut down.
- Yes, 2020, it was right before it, yeah.
- Yeah, 'cause that was the one I had to miss
'cause I was out of the country on vacation
when it happened.
- Yeah.
- Not in China, I hope.
- No, I was in Thailand for a friend's wedding.
- Interesting, nice.
- That was back in the day when we kept track
of what countries do have COVID cases,
not how many cases in every country.
So it was a different time.
- Yeah.
- A while ago.
- So I only have like, I guess one,
I don't have anything to show for this,
but I did a couple extra things.
It wasn't gonna talk about it too much,
but I did notice that pip is now at 22,
version 22 dot something.
It's what, we're at 2202 now.
But one of the neat things about it is
there's some cool stuff around having pip vendor.
There's a couple neat things.
There's a one of the, they're vendored some of rich.
So some of the, especially the error output.
If everything goes great,
you probably won't notice much of a difference,
except for maybe the progress bar if things are slow.
But the error report if something goes wrong,
like if it's building something,
that's where things apparently show up really neat,
some better error outputs.
And better error outputs are always great.
Also, interesting that they replaced talks
in their development workflow with NOX.
And I don't know if that's worth noting or not,
but it's interesting nonetheless.
- Yeah, I know Pradyun, one of the core developers of Pip
is a big Knox fan.
I'm also a Knox fan.
So I think part of that's just kind of the difference.
For those of you who don't know the difference
between TOX and Knox, other than the letter,
Knox is a bit more of a, I would say, general task runner.
So because you can write just straight,
it's writing just straight Python code.
So I think for projects that like to use it
for like release process stuff,
like on the packaging project,
Pragen wrote a Knox file that has like literally
a release command that will do everything you need
from within Knox.
So you don't have to have a separate shell script
or something else.
So it can all be in the same file that you also specify
how to run your linter and how to run your tests and stuff.
So.
- That's pretty neat.
One of the things that I've,
and I don't remember if there's a way to get around it
or not, TOX operates in a virtual environment.
So it creates, so one of the things,
the default behavior at least,
creates a virtual environment and then runs,
runs whatever you're gonna have it do
within that virtual environment.
So like the idea being,
you're gonna have multiple Python versions.
So it creates a virtual environment
for each Python version that you're running.
There's some stuff like this extra stuff,
like I just want to publish now.
I'm already like, I'm already in a virtual environment
'cause I'm always in a virtual environment.
I don't really need a Tox to generate another one
just to run a command.
Is that sort, do you know if that sort of thing
is easier in Knox or does Knox also create
a virtual environment before it does stuff?
- So Knox can create a virtual environment.
I can't remember if it does automatically for every command.
- Putting you on the spot.
But it's something I'll look up there.
Ask Thea, she can tell you.
- Yeah, yeah, definitely.
So, go ahead.
- Sorry, I was gonna say that,
speaking of pip being updated,
I was trying to use it with pip Tools today,
and it seems that pip Tools is not working
with the latest version of PIP, just FYI.
There's an open issue, I'm sure the team's investigating,
but for all pip Tools users, they're not alone.
- Yeah, so the problem, yeah, so I can, yeah.
So what happened was is pip-tools is using
the private API of pip and it changed.
And so pip-tools broke.
So pip-tools, if you use it,
you will need to pin to a version of pip 2021 or older
to work with pip-tools until they figure out
what they need to do to use the changes
that pip made to their internal API.
- And to be fair to the pip-tools team,
- pip 22 just came out like a handful of days ago.
So it's really new.
- Yeah.
- I'm a huge fan of pip-tools, definitely love it.
- Well, one other thing actually.
- Yeah, just one other thing on the new pip release
for people to be aware of.
So one thing that happened here is to try to cut down
on the vendoring, pip stopped vendoring HTML5 lib
and now use the HTML parser in the standard library.
And that actually broke a bunch of
simple repo API indexes.
For those of you who don't know the simple repo API,
if you go to any URL in PyPI for a project
and replace the project part of the URL with simple,
you'll see what I'm talking about.
But basically there's a spec that just says,
There's a PEP that says, hey, write this HTML
and then packaging installers can read it
and figure out where to find all the files
and the projects for something.
It turns out a lot of people weren't following the spec.
And so a lot of these indexes broke
because pip wasn't able to read them anymore
because it couldn't be parsed as pure HTML.
They were doing funky things that broke.
So they, I believe, either have or are planning to roll it back
with a flag to let you alternatively use HTML5 Lib for now
with the goal of getting all these projects
that have broken output, they don't follow the spec,
to fix themselves so that they can go back
to not having HTML5 Lib in the box.
So just a heads up, if you use an alternative package index
and it suddenly broke, that's why they're working on a fix.
But I would talk to the project that creates that index for you
and have them work on making sure
that that project creates valid HTML5 that
can be parsed by the HTML parser in the standard library.
So that--
>> OK.
>> --because that'll probably go away in pip 23.
>> But it's not broken now, right?
It's just-- it's flagged?
>> It was broken.
They didn't realize how much of the world was doing invalid
HTML for these indexes.
So I don't know if it's in 22.0.2
or if it's going to be in the next release.
But there is an open issue where they're--
I at least was looking at where they were fixing it.
Because I got looped in because I have one of my side projects,
Mouse Bender, that actually wrote some code around this
originally.
There's talk about moving up to packaging,
about a lot of behind-the-scenes stuff
that people don't need to care about.
But the--
[INTERPOSING VOICES]
Yeah.
>>No, go ahead.
>>Well, I was just going to say, so the plan is, I think,
to add a flag to say use old HTML parser
or something along those lines for now.
So you can say, hey, use the HTML5 lib version
of parsing HTML, but it's just to be clear here,
there will be a fix, but it's a temporary fix
'cause people should be getting after their projects
that create these indexes to do the right thing
and actually follow the standard.
- Okay, so as someone that got bit by this,
because we have an internal PyPI caching server
that also we store our own stuff on and we don't own it.
We like, it's a third party thing that we're licensed.
So I don't know how long it's going to be.
So hopefully that, hopefully they move quickly,
but at the same time, hopefully this extra,
use the old one flag or whatever will work for a while.
I was a little surprised when I saw the warning pop up
of like, oh, you're not using a good, you know,
it's invalid HTML.
And I'm like, what am I supposed to do about it?
(laughing)
- Well, and I don't think the developers were expecting it
to be so widely broken either, right?
It's like, what are these projects doing
that are creating invalid HTML?
But apparently--
- Oh, I did it all the time though.
Like, okay, just to be fair, if it works, it works.
It's HTML.
- Yeah, well, and that was the problem, right?
Is the spec, the PEP that defines it very specifically says
it must be valid HTML5.
And I think it was specifically so that it could be parsed
by the standard library.
So it also means none of these pages
could have even been parsed by the standard library.
So I think that's what happened, right?
Is people, because people,
because pip had been using HTML5 lib,
which is obviously way more lax
in terms of what it can parse,
everyone just like, "Oh, okay, it's good enough."
And didn't realize that the spec
specifically mandated valid HTML5.
And so hopefully all these projects that got caught up
can get a fix out over the next year.
'Cause as I said, I suspect this will be in until pip 23,
which will come out in 2023.
So it's not like it's gonna disappear in a month,
this flag.
So we'll let the fix out,
but hopefully everyone can kind of get caught up
so that they can get back to not vendoring HTML5.
- Okay.
Before we go jump to a joke,
I want one last extra is for the first time in like 18,
20 months, I'm not writing a book.
(laughing)
I'm no longer writing this book.
The writing is done.
The editing is done.
So it's off to all the rest of the cogs
that have to go through the process to get it.
But the ebook right now is really solid.
So anybody that grabs the ebook now,
if you've grabbed it before, all the updates are there,
but this has got all the copy edit changes
and the final edits, the rest of its layout and stuff
to try to get the physical book for him.
So that's coming out sometime this month, maybe, hopefully.
So that's my hope is by the end of February,
I'll have a physical copy in my hands.
- Well, congratulations.
Everyone who listens to this podcast
and Testing Code and anywhere else for you,
know you put a lot of blood, sweat, tears
and love into that book.
So congratulations for reaching this point.
- Well, I just was realizing that my youngest is 12.
My youngest daughter is 12.
I spent a year and a half on this book,
a year and a half on the first edition.
So I've been writing about Pytest in book form
for a quarter of her life.
It's pretty weird.
Are you ready for a joke?
- I should thank you for your work, Brian.
(laughing)
I'm gonna be ready to physical hobby, hopefully.
- So one of the goals of the second edition
was to try to put it in a format
that would be easier to teach and learn.
So the next step is I'm gonna work on
trying to teach people in person
and through video courses and stuff like that,
turn this into, 'cause I know a lot of people don't read,
but you're coders, why don't you read?
You have to read your code, but still,
some people don't read books.
How about something funny?
- Yes.
- Today's joke brought to you by Luciana.
Thank you for finding something funny.
And we'll add this to the thing.
So I love this.
So for people listening, there's a picture of an ocean
and you've got a really big ship.
It's called, I don't know what's on the ship.
It's a big ship.
- I don't know what you're talking about.
I don't know, but it says,
but it looks all official like and everything.
And it says proper software design.
And then there's a guy on a surfboard standing up.
So it's like a wakeboard thing.
And he's holding an umbrella,
getting pulled by an umbrella on a surfboard
and says, whatever I'm doing.
So it's funny.
- That's how I feel whenever I'm coding.
- And sometimes it feels like this going from,
from the old days of like these huge design documents
to now, oh, we're doing agile.
So let's just write some ideas on some Post-it notes
and stick them on board and run from it with there.
- If it works, it works, right?
- Yeah, it's got tests, right?
Well, I think so.
It's unit tested, it's 100% coverage.
It's good, let's ship it.
So perfect.
Nice.
First of all, thank you, Luciana, for joining the show.
I think it's your first time, right?
- Yes, it was my first podcast.
- Awesome. - Participation.
Thank you for having me,
and thanks, Brett, for joining last minute.
(both laughing)
- Yeah, thanks, Brett.
It's always good to see you.
- I'm happy to play the fake Michael for this episode.
(both laughing)
- Thanks, everybody, on the stream for showing up,
and we'll see you all next week.
Thanks for listening to Python Bytes.
Follow the show on Twitter via @PythonBytes.
That's Python Bytes as in B-Y-T-E-S.
Get the full show notes over at PythonBytes.fm.
If you have a news item we should cover, just visit PythonBytes.fm
and click Submit in the nav bar. We're always on the lookout for sharing something cool.
If you want to join us for the live recording, just visit the website and click Live Stream
to get notified of when our next episode goes live.
That's usually happening at noon Pacific on Wednesdays on YouTube.
This is Brian Okken. On behalf of myself and Michael Kennedy,
thank you for listening and sharing this podcast with your friends and colleagues.